did it we just crossed a major milestone
on YouTube after being here for eight
years
first the quarter channel in the
Samaniego channel now the corridor crew
channel we finally crossed a million
subscribers and to celebrate we're gonna
go run over and ask everybody what their
favorite moment was from the past couple
years we're gonna make a compilation
here in this video and you can watch all
the videos in a playlist give the I in
the corner of description below and take
the journey with us
so let's go back and let's look at the
best moments on the corridor crew
channel ooh my favorite moment that's so
much and he was in so many moments this
channel his channel joined the YouTube
favorite 18 2011 only a big Holi hosen
Ren jumped over the door with the axe
and embeds it in the wall and his swings
out of it
Wow some of those things that I don't
know if you thought it through but if
that axe lived while he was swimming
through we were just coming boom right
to his face I don't have a favorite
video
[Applause]
unsnap that was a spark
Oh fine run the cameras
[Music]
it's really hard to boil three years
worth of moments than to use like just
like a single moment okay everybody on
the board of her channel is falling off
the cliff told my wife I loved her
challenge that one just like when I saw
that little green screen effect that's
like that's that is my style humor right
there there's Lee's that is it boiled
down to a single shot I love it
part of what I do here is making sure we
get those videos in so it's clear to see
mostly the stuff I missed like
expressions like all stuff that we're
doing them behind the scenes it's dead
like since I'm just so scrambled or
running around sometimes or nothing you
know other things are about the shoot
it's cool to go back and actually see
things that happen on set that I might
not have been there for I had actually
just graduated high school in June 2010
it was when we were shooting the
lightsaber stuff and Sam was in the
chair a faithful thanks to Lenovo for
providing us with these Jedi challenges
and giving us an experience like never
before
Jedi challenges are available right now
at Best Buy and also more updates to the
game are coming soon so
Jenay challenges is available right now
at Best Buy and if you want to learn
more you can also go to the Jedi
challenges calm it is right we can
release it now though okay that was one
of the great it's just cutaways if
February 2011 I was in my second
semester of law school I was hanging out
with Sam and Nico we were just kind of
shooting stuff when they had time or
when I had time to hang out with him and
help him but I didn't even end up
quitting that job and going to work with
them until May of that year so this is
where it all started when he first moved
out to Los Angeles ten years ago he
moved to this you know he's number six
Freddie and Brandon moved in with me and
Sam we start working on videos together
we're working on a movie actually called
dark I went back in the day then
eventually we moved into unit 3 and this
is where the corridor channel and the
Freddie W channel were born here in unit
3 so I moved in here together all four
of us me Sam Brannan and Freddie here
are all our desks you actually see the
spots here in the chairs more down where
he said this is where Judy said her
Freddie said I was over here in the
corner over here eventually
Freddie and Brandon moved out to unit 6
because the Freddie W operations are
getting too big becchi Jake's dust
became the spot over here I'm just
working working worked and made videos
but even his whole place is filled up
with equipment computers wires or acts
of props it'll prop room in the back hmm
I'm back in the day there's a video
about lenses that Niko does it's a good
like how to learn about lenses video ego
gets like a little bit defensive about
one of his nose he's like I like my
lenses and it's that to me is very funny
February of 2011 yeah yeah so I was
already working full-time production I
was probably a day one subscriber which
is really funny since I ended up working
here probably one of my favorite videos
that I always show people when I'm first
show
or if I just want a good laugh because I
it's just like one of the most
entertaining videos if you're new here
go check it out it's in the playlist
it's the mario kart video we did
Peter yeah favorite video on the corner
creature oh it has to be the one we're
talking about the ones my first vlog
video where I got shot with an arrow
yeah I know it's my claim to fame he not
your shirt for sake frames there you can
animate an arrow for like one frame and
then reveal it it's like literally such
an easy fact but with the sound effect
February 2011 I was in eighth grade
hmm what we're doing February 2011 I
can't remember what I did last week do
ya I was like just doing PA work just
start doing PA work I got my Facebook
June 2011 so I don't have anything for
February unfortunately I don't know oh
that's easy the one that just came out
featuring salmon is baby because I have
never seen that side of Sam before I've
known Sam for years and I've never seen
that side of Sam before so that was kind
of nice I was smiling the entire time I
was watching it was hard not to smile
what's up son Jake showed me this video
of Brett and Ben and I told like after
watching it I told like four or five
people about it and I think that's the
first time I've done that what was it
when Brett was like trying to shoot guns
- yes that's not know I'm a shave you
son - Jake is like dude who would write
something like this and Jake was like I
think I got idea heard up to Bret and it
said I'm a shave you son and Bret's like
he's like sawing some wood and he just
goes like I don't know who would ever
write that son you have no idea who this
is
and he's like son he's like I've never
seen that my lifetime that made that
made me laugh so hard so we had a little
stint in unit five when Brandon let us
stay there rotor getting installation
and air conditioning now I remember that
I think I was like probably the birth of
the through corridor crew channel as
they know it today when comic love Nick
really found the stride the stories
really started to just spill out of the
cameras it was pretty great
here we are Hector corridor digital I
dunno where the digital is at the end of
the name what it's because when we
started the company every else is like
so-and-so studios so-and-so pictures
so-and-so productions but we figured
we're doing everything digitally this is
remember this is it still at the era
where digital cameras and film were
competing I was like a film so organic
digital never be as good no I can screw
it we're all digital we do play video
games
we make videos would you VFX it's all in
our computers so we're corridor digital
I just want to say a big thank you to
all our patrons for helping support the
corridor channel in the corridor
really means a lot to us there's a
couple of you I want to give a personal
thank you to for example Seth the mad
scientist
Gary Dolph Richard Linder Rory Sill Hawk
why Taylor Dunbar
Ulrich Kim Kim Colin Keaton I think
that's right Mitch hello and ski I'm
butchering all these names man it's like
I'm a substitute teacher right now
glitch cue that one's easy James Bailey
I know that one
Brian and toesik I think I've been
pronouncing that right all these months
and of course the one and only richard
black brain thank you guys for your
support we really appreciate it and to
all the rest of our patrons out there
thank you so much for making this
possible and if you're considering
becoming one of our patrons well please
go check it out there's a link in the
description below we offer a bunch of
cool rewards we do it hang out with you
guys every month another good stuff like
that and of course you help make what we
do here possible so when everybody else
is worrying about an ad pocalypse we're
not thanks to you guys over the past
month made a lot of new viewers come to
this channel thank you and welcome I
hope you are enjoying your stay here if
you want to see the collection of all
these videos and take a little trip in
the past and see what we're all about
here check out the playlist link below
or a little I in the corner you'll pop
out and bring you to a playlist of all
these best moments on the corridor ku
channel and if you like it consider
subscribing and if you don't well that's
fine - it's a free world man but like it
if you subscribed